tik tok zerstört unsere
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne ich kann keine
Buchseite mehr am Stück lesen tik tok
macht seelisch krank tiktok macht
süchtig das und noch viel mehr wird in
der populärpresse gerne behauptet und
vielleicht findet sich auch der ein oder
die andere von euch selbst darin wieder
vielleicht habt ihr diese Meldungen
gesehen und gedacht ja ich kann mich
wirklich nicht mehr lange auf etwas
konzentrieren aber liegt das wirklich an
tiktok wir wollten es genauer wissen und
haben uns angeguckt was die Wissenschaft
dazu sagt und Spoiler die Antworten sind
nicht halb so klar wie immer wieder
behauptet wird und manchmal wird auch
ziemlicher Bullshit verzeihen z.B von
Dopamin Detox Gurus die tiktok mit
Heroin gleichsetzen und dann gibt es
noch eine ganz große Lüge die jeder von
euch kennt und die sogar von einer
Bekannten Psychologin verbreitet wird
deswegen herzlich willkommen bei dr
Watson wo wir über echte Wissenschaft
sprechen
die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne ist nicht das
was ihr denkt zumindest nicht wenn wir
die Definition in der Psychologie meinen
eigentlich beschreibt sie die Menge an
Informationen die man in einem kurzen
Zeitraum aufnehmen kann es ist also
keine Zeitspanne landläufig meinen wir
mit Aufmerksamkeitsspanne aber eher wie
lange man sich auf einzelne Aufgaben
konzentrieren kann die wirkliche Frage
ist also kann die Jugend von heute
überhaupt noch lang genug stehen sitzen
um einen Doktor Watson Video von vorne
bis hinten anzugucken statt nach 49,4%
abzuschalten und zwar auf Normal
Geschwindigkeit und ohne sich
gleichzeitig mit irgendetwas anderem zu
beschäftigen ja hallo ja ich rede mit
dir das ist kein Podcast beim
nachforschen haben wir nämlich sehr
schnell bemerkt tiktok gibt es noch gar
nicht lange genug und verändert sich zu
schnell für brauchbare
neuropsychologische Forschungsergebnisse
es gibt aber einige Studien zu den
negativen Auswirkungen von Social Media
allgemein von Smartphones und dem
Internet die sich auf tiktok übertragen
lassen lass uns also mal darüber
sprechen
zum einen wäre da das Problem der
dauernden Ablenkung
viele Apps lenken uns ständig mit
Benachrichtigungen ab auch tiktok es
nutzt damit die Angst etwas zu verpassen
fear of missing out oder fomo die
Benachrichtigungen verlocken natürlich
dazu unter der Schulbank im
Vorlesungssaal oder im Büro mal eben zu
checken was gerade so los ist jetzt
könnte man vielleicht meinen so eine
kurze Ablenkung schadet ja nicht aber
die Forschung an Multitasking zeigt
Multitasking gibt es gar nicht man kann
nicht wirklich mehrere Dinge
gleichzeitig machen die unsere bewusste
Aufmerksamkeit brauchen stattdessen
konzentriert man sich nacheinander immer
wieder auf etwas Neues verliert aber
aber jedes mal ein bisschen Zeit man
sollte also eher von task switching
sprechen außerdem wartet man unbewusst
immer auf die nächste Benachrichtigung
und das ist eine kognitive
Dauerbelastung die sich auch negativ auf
die Konzentrationsfähigkeit auswirken
könnte wie diese Studie hier gezeigt hat
das gleiche gilt übrigens auch wenn man
in seiner Freizeit E-Mails DMS und
Benachrichtigungen von seinem Chef
bekommen moment mal wer hat das
geschrieben
Benachrichtigungen und sogar die
ständige Erwartung einer
Benachrichtigung können uns ablenken sie
sind eine unterschwellige Dauerbelastung
eine weitere Dauerbelastung die sich auf
die Konzentrationsfähigkeit auswirkt
sind seelische Probleme und auch da
steht Social Media in der Kritik deshalb
unsere nächste Frage ist Social Media
wirklich schlecht für die Psyche
oft hört man das Social Media sich
gerade bei jungen Menschen negativ auf
das Wohlbefinden auswirkt vor allem die
Buddy Image und Selbstwertprobleme
werden im Zusammenhang mit Foto und
Video Apps häufig thematisiert
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer vergleichen sich
mit der perfekten Selbstdarstellung von
influencern und influencerinnen und das
kannst Du Probleme mit der
Selbstwahrnehmung und zu
Minderwertigkeitsgefühlen führen also
macht tiktok und psychisch krank
psychische Probleme sind sehr oft
Depressionen oder werden von
Depressionen begleitet bei der Recherche
zu Depressionen unter Social Media
Nutzerinnen und Nutzern haben wir
erstmal kein klares Bild ausmachen
können große Meter Analysen die viele
Studien zu dem Thema zusammenfassen
zeigen nur kleine Effekte also ja bei
denen die Social Media besonders
intensiv nutzen waren Depressionen im
Durchschnitt häufiger aber eben nur ein
bisschen eine Erklärung dafür lieferte
eine Studie die sich angeschaut hat wie
die Menschen Social Media nutzten aktive
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer liken Videos
tauschen sich mit Gleichgesinnten in den
Kommentaren aus verschaffen ihrem
Lieblingskanal einen Publikumspreis beim
Grimma Online Award danke dafür oder
erstellen sogar selbst kreative Inhalte
unter diesen Menschen korrelierte eine
intensive Nutzung sogar mit weniger
Depressionen ihr solltet also vielleicht
tatsächlich mehr die Videos liken und
kommentieren
passive Nutzerinnen und Nutzer lassen
sich berieseln und geben sich
stundenlang doomscrolling hin bei ihnen
stieg die Zahl der Depressionen mit
intensiver Nutzung was mir persönlich
geholfen hat bewusst damit meiner Zeit
umzugehen und gar nicht erst in den Sog
des doomscrollings zu geraten war
lustigerweise eine Uhr und zwar ganz
bewusst keines SmartWatch sondern eine
ganz analoge in meinem Fall die von
unserem Partner Holzkern die dieses
Video hier möglich gemacht haben Uhren
wie diese hier sehen einfach schick aus
und bestehen zusätzlich noch aus
natürlichen Materialien primär natürlich
aus Holz daher auch der Name Holzkern
diese hier läuft sogar mit Solarenergie
was ich persönlich sehr cool finde klar
man kann natürlich auch einfach aus sein
Handy schauen um die Zeit zu checken
aber das wirkt natürlich wieder die
Gefahr der Ablenkung und sind wir mal
ehrlich so eine schicke solar-armbanduhr
aus Holz ist doch einfach etwas
Besonderes das ist quasi Innovation und
technischer Fortschritt am Handgelenk
wenn ihr aber einfach keine Uhr tragen
wollt dann hat Holzkern auch noch ganz
viele andere coole Accessoires im
Angebot zum Beispiel diese Sonnenbrille
hier oder Ohrringe oder Armbänder Ketten
und vieles mehr alles natürlich per Hand
gefertigt aus Holz und damit immer ein
Unikat schaut doch mal bei Holzkern
vorbei und unterstützt uns gleichzeitig
damit klickt einfach auf den ersten Link
unten in der Videobeschreibung oder
nutzt den Code Watson 15 für 15 % Rabatt
so genug Ablenkung jetzt geht's zurück
zu tiktok und unsere Aufmerksamkeit
spannend heißt das jetzt das ist Social
Media die Menschen depressiv macht wenn
sie sie nur passiv nutzen
nicht unbedingt solche Studien sind
Momentaufnahmen und sie zeigen
Korrelationen auf aber das ist sehr
wichtig keine Kausalitäten vielleicht
machst du einen scrollen depressiv
vielleicht neigen aber auch depressive
Menschen zum doomscrollen beides ist
plausibel und vielleicht stimmt auch
beides und damit kommen wir auch wieder
zur Aufmerksamkeit denn ähnliches fand
diese Studie hier bei Teenagern mit
Aufmerksamkeitsstörungen
auch hier korreliert Social Media
Nutzung mit der Stärke der Symptome und
auch hier kam es wieder darauf an wie
Social Media genutzt wurde nicht wie
intensiv wenn die Nutzung den normalen
Lebenswandel beeinträchtigte dann
verstärkte das die Symptome zum Beispiel
wenn die Teenager Schlafprobleme
bekommen haben weil sie bis spät abends
noch tiktoks geguckt haben zur
Sicherheit aber noch der Hinweis aDHS
ist angeboren und entwickelt sich in der
frühen Kindheit das kann also nicht
durch Social Media ausgelöst werden
Social Media kann aber Symptome
verstärken oder Aufmerksamkeitsdefizite
bei Menschen ohne ADHS auslösen wenn die
Nutzung mit schlechten Angewohnheiten
verbunden ist dann ist der Grund für die
Aufmerksamkeit Probleme aber zum
Beispiel Schlafmangel und nicht direkt
Social Media okay aber was wenn man die
schlechten Angewohnheiten überhaupt
nicht mehr unter Kontrolle bekommt
Social Media inklusive Betreiber und
creditern ist darauf spezialisiert euch
auf der App zu halten wir tun das
übrigens auch
tik tok ist allerdings besonders perfide
denn wo man auf youtube seine Videos auf
der Startseite noch unter vielen
Thumbnails gezielt aussucht zeigt tiktok
immer nur ein Video auf einmal und das
hält euch extra lange in der App wie das
let me explain in den 1960ern hat der
Psychologe BF Skinner Tauben in einen
Kasten mit einer kleinen Scheibe
gesteckt picken Sie die Scheibe dann
bekamen sie eine Belohnung nice die
Tauben lernten das und holten sich dann
Belohnungen bis sie genug hatten aber
dann veränderte Skinner das Muster nun
kamen die Belohnungen zufällig mal nach
einem picken mal nach drei Mal nach zwei
das erstaunliche Ergebnis war dass die
Tauben wie blöde ständig weiter gepickt
haben immer in der Erwartung nach so
viel Enttäuschung muss doch irgendwann
mal die nächste Belohnung kommen Skin
aber überzeugt dass ich das selber
Verhalten auch in Menschen zeigt und für
mich klingt das jedenfalls sehr nach
tiktok oder Twitter oder tinder oder
Glücksspielautomaten oder
Kurkuma kanalzappen im Fernsehen
irgendwann muss doch das nächste gute
Ding kommen tiktok macht also das was
alles Social Media Plattformen machen
nur extrem gut deswegen hat es auch die
größte Verweildauer unter allen Social
Media Plattformen und um das zu
erreichen trickst es unser
Belohnungssystem aus okay wir haben uns
jetzt angeschaut wie sich Social Media
und tik tok indirekt auf eure
Konzentrationsfähigkeit auswirken
könnten und wir haben sehr
differenzierte Antworten gefunden bleibt
eine Frage könnten tiktoks und andere
Video kurzformate auch direkt euer
Gehirn verändern und es immer
unkonzentrierter machen
immer wieder wird behauptet dass von
Generation zu Generationen die
Konzentrationsfähigkeit schlechter
werden würde es gibt sogar eine
Hypothese über den Mechanismus die
Kurzvideos sollen die Kids daran
gewöhnen Informationen immer nur in
kleinen Happen mit viel Trara und
regelmäßigen belohnungsgefühlen zu
bekommen und deshalb würden ihre Gehirne
dann irgendwann nach der Mittleren tik
tok videodauer frustriert abschalten
wenn man sie bis dahin nicht irgendwie
belohnt hat mit einem Gag oder so das
alles geht auf einen Report von
Microsofts Werbeabteilung zurück der
2012 herauskam dieser zitierte wiederum
den Think Tank Statistik brain der keine
echten Daten für diese Behauptung
vorweisen kann mit Microsofts eigener
Studie hat es auch gar nicht zu tun sie
haben einfach nur 1200 Kanadier zu ihrem
Internetverhalten befragt die Behauptung
die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne der Menschen
sein zwischen kürzer als die eines
goldfischs war eben nur als fun fact
gedacht das ist dafür gar keine Evidenz
gehabt wahrscheinlich nicht nur den
Leuten bei Microsoft entgangen sondern
auch der die diesen Quatsch immer noch
munter weiter verbreitet besonders
ärgerlich ist dass wohl auch Menschen
wie dr Julie allbright auf den Zug
aufgesprungen sind sie ist Psychologin
und hat das Märchen von der schwindenden
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne mit verbreitet zum
Beispiel in diesem Interview dabei hat
sie keine Forschung zu dem Thema
veröffentlicht und zitiert auch keine
Studien die ihre Thesen bestätigen weil
es keine gibt die wenigen Studien die
sie erwähnt bearbeiten die Fragestellung
auch überhaupt nicht stattdessen bringt
sie eine bumer Anekdote nach der anderen
und macht sich darüber lustig wenn
Schüler und Studenten keinen
Fünfjahresplan haben wie Call Bullshit
also was bedeutet das jetzt für eure
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne bzw korrekter
gesagt eure Konzentrationsfähigkeit nun
es kommt darauf an wenn ihr Social Media
aktiv nutzt um soziale Kontakte zu
pflegen euch über eure Lieblingsthemen
auszutauschen oder euch kreativ
auszuleben dann ist Social Media eine
wirklich tolle Sache trotzdem sollte man
darauf achten dass man sich keine
schlechten Gewohnheiten aneignet die
dann z.B zu Schlafmangel führen
eigentlich logisch wenn ihr aber sehr
viel Zeit damit verbringt passiv tik tok
zu konsumieren dann kann das ein Zeichen
sein dass etwas nicht stimmt muss aber
nicht und das Problem ist dann
vermutlich seltener der Social Media
Konsum selbst sondern eher persönliche
Probleme wie z.B Stress dass wir uns
nicht mehr lange auf etwas konzentrieren
können weil das Gehirn sich daran
gewöhnt das ist wohl frei erfunden aber
das tiktok wegen eines psychologischen
Tricks besonders gut daran ist einen auf
der Plattform zu halten das erscheint
uns hingegen zumindest plausibel also
beobachtet euren Social Media Konsum
genau legt den Fokus mehr auf das Social
und weniger auf das Media und bevor
jetzt das Handy ausmacht was ihr
definitiv bald mal tun solltet schaut
euch noch dieses eine super interessante
und kurzweilige Video von uns an das
erklärt wieso ich mir tiktok trotzdem
nicht installieren werde ansonsten
bleibt neugierig euer Patrick